It seems that rag is so 2023 and
everywhere you go you see my first rag
and rag pipelines and everything is rag
related as if it's already solved but
actually not really well I'm Ival with
me is Niv we both work at A21 labs and
today we're going to talk about why rag
evaluation is broken and how to fix it
and the reason that rag evaluation is
broken comes from a lot of things but
mostly because how easy it is to build
benchmarks the way humans are regular to
think. And what I mean by that is that
most benchmarks comprise from local
questions that has local answers. There
is some sort of assumption that the
answer lies in a certain chunk in the
data. Makes sense, right? What is the
most natural way to build such a
benchmark? to go read some long
document, find a question that the
answer lies somewhere inside and then
this is the golden answer and there are
a lot of benchmarks who try to overcome
that a lot of multiple hope questions
famously frames by Google but those
questions are not really realistic right
something like if my future wife have
the same name of the 15 first lady of
the United States mother and her surname
like what is this does Does it even mean
something? Does it represent something
real? Not really. This is all very
manufactured and not really
representative of the real world.
There's also not a holistic way to test
the entire system. Most of the
benchmarks are either retrieval only
benchmark, meaning that we try to
retrieve the best segments or the best
chunks for our database and we assume
that again the answer is in one or two
or several of them. or it's generation
only benchmarks which is essentially
just grounding benchmark right just to
see that we can answer a question based
on the context that are already in the
prompt. But what about chunking? What
about parsing? What about specific cases
that do not actually have this effect of
the question uh directs us to a certain
place in the data. The answer is not as
simple and really that's the main
problem here that benchmarks do not
correlate with real world data that real
world data is messier. Each data is
different and this thing is not really
generalized as well. We have some sort
of a vicious cycle when we are
developing a rug system where we're
building a rug system for flawed
benchmarks because you have to optimize
for something and then when we get high
scores we celebrate about it. We write a
nice post whether on Slack, on LinkedIn,
on Twitter and then look at us, we're so
good. But then when we actually give it
to users or we test it on customer data,
we see that they struggle. It's not as
good as we hoped. So we create new
benchmarks, optimize for them, and we're
showing that we're the best. But those
benchmarks probably have the same
problems. And this goes over and over
and over. rag pipelines with local
questions and local answers. That's what
we have in most of the cases. So how do
we fix
it? Um so we will not uh say uh how we
will fix everything but we'll try to fix
some things. Uh so for example if you
take like a f financial data like
finance bench or others uh like SEC
filings or any other financial data you
may imagine that someone would ask
aggregative questions such as which
company has reported the highest
quarterly revenue the most times or in
how many fiscal years did Apple exceed
hundred billion in annual revenue? Um or
at least all of something. Uh so so you
may imagine how rag systems uh currently
do on such questions because they are so
limited and they just grab the top k
chunks that they get and try to compile
an answer by that. that uh when you
encounter a questions like all Fortune
500 companies so imagine that you bring
10 chunks uh then maybe you will get
another Fortune 500 company in the 11th
one and the 12th one and uh for every n
you can consider the n plus one. Uh so
these problems really make uh rag
systems
struggle. Um so we try to to estimate
how uh how do a current system do with
such questions. So we built an a corpus
a small corpus of uh like 22 uh 22
documents uh from the historical pages
of FIFA World Cup uh in Wikipedia. Uh so
this is our corpus and uh we asked uh
many questions about this corpus such as
which team has won the FIFA World Cup
the most times in how many FIFA World
Cup did Brazil participate and uh we
used the we used the knowledge base the
wiki data and kegle knowledge bases to
answer these
questions and uh as you can see a common
rag pipeline like the the first one
you'll see on lang chain or lama index
and open responses both fail
miserably. It's 5% and 11% of the
questions answered correctly and these
are questions that you can find the
answer to in very local segments as you
all
mentioned.
Um so our idea to handle such corpuses
um is take this unstructured corpus and
convert it into a data structure and
then ask the question on top of this
data structure because essentially the
questions we talked about are questions
SQL questions right it's just like how
many times or it's counting questions or
max and min questions or um calculation
questions and you just it does it just
doesn't doesn't make sense to try to
answer these questions by going over the
pages uh or or specific chunks of the
pages. Um so how do we do it? Uh we
split it in two uh similarly to how a
regular rag flow is done and where you
invest the compute in the ingestion and
you try to do things quickly in the
inference. So in the ingesttor phase uh
we first cluster the document into
subcorpuses. For example, we may have
financial corpus and FIFA World Cup
corpus that we uh do this clustering.
Then per each subc corpus we identify
the schema that I that uh represents
this corpus. uh we populate the schema
according to each and every document and
finally we upload the results into an
SQLB. Uh so for example if you have the
C the FIFA corpus and you have a schema
which is compiled of a year the winner
the top three teams the top scorer and
many other
attributes and then um you use an LLM we
it's not just an LLM it's like a
pipeline but um its goal is to populate
the schema for every document at the
inference flow uh whenever we have a
query we identify the schema that is
relevant for this query, for example, is
it a financial question or a FIFA World
Cup question? And then we just do a
regular text to ask you over our data
and we return the final
answer. Um, so here for the FIFA World
Cup, which team has won the most the
FIFA World Cup the most times? It's just
a simple SQL
query. Um, this approach does not come
to solve everything. H not at all. uh
first and foremost not every corpus or
query is a relational DB material and
not every corpus is homogeneous in terms
of the uh the attributes. H it doesn't
necessarily contain a schema underlying
it. Um but we do see many such corpuses
with our clients. um
normalization even with a toy example
such as the FIFA World Cup, we see the
struggle with building the correct
schema. H because um for example in the
host country you have West Germany but
then if I want to ask how many times did
Germany won does West Germany count or
doesn't it? A host country is it a
singular attribute or is it a list
because South Korea and Japan hosted
together the World Cup? Um so the
normalization is an issue both during
the ingestion and
inference and abstinence or ambiguity.
Um what happens if a user asks me did
Real Madrid win the 2006 final? It's not
a World Cup but I do see some things
that I can try to do with my schema and
as you probably know LLM's
try tend to try to please the users.
um the the points in the ingestion where
we try to cluster and they infer the
schema. Uh there's some tradeoff here on
the complexity and how fine grained we
are and how much compute uh we would
like to invest during the ingestion
time. Um and finally the text to SQL
where whenever the schemas become
complex is just a complex issue uh which
is very known and studied.
Um so the main takeaways uh are just
that rag is not a one-sizefits-all
system and you have to account for every
client separately. Um the there are of
course clusters but we should um we
should note that the uh regular pipeline
of chunking embedding uh retrieving
reranking is not good enough for many
questions.
um existing benchmarks fail to capture
this uh these uh use cases. Uh as you
mentioned, they are very limited. Um and
in order to solve the problems, we may
need to go beyond standard rug for
specific
settings. If you thought this is
interesting and you want to learn more
about structure drag and the problems
with rugg evaluation, please check out
our full episode of YAP podcast by A21.
Thank you.